[Música]
este sábado el ministro de defensa de
Rusia sergeygu visitó las tropas rusas
en el frente estuvo en zonas devastadas
y entregó medallas a los soldados la
inteligencia británica confirmó que el
ejército ucraniano enfrenta la presión
de las fuerzas rusas en ciudad que el
grupo Wagner dice tener prácticamente
rodeada
el presidente francés está en la
República democrática del Congo la
última parada de su gira para renovar
las relaciones con el continente
africano en King shasa macron anunció
una iniciativa de ayuda por 34 millones
de euros para el este del país y aseguró
que todos los actores del conflicto
armado están de acuerdo con un alto el
fuego
en Colombia este viernes 79 policías y
seis civiles fueron liberados después de
ser retenidos en una protesta campesina
contra la petrolera emerald energys aquí
en los locales acusan de daños
ambientales en la zona tenemos análisis
en esta edición
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición con información
relativa a la guerra de en Ucrania
porque este sábado en un acontecimiento
poco frecuente el ministro de defensa de
Rusia hablamos de sergeygu visitó a las
tropas rusas que combaten en Ucrania se
trata de una de las raras ocasiones en
las que un alto comandante ruso ha
visitado el frente desde que Putin lanzó
su llamada operación militar especial
hace más de un año a través de Telegram
el Ministerio de defensa de Moscú
publicó imágenes de shoygu condecorando
a los combatientes rusos visitando zonas
devastadas del dombas e inspeccionando
un puesto de Mando en el sur de idonesk
recordemos que shuigu en el cargo desde
2014 ha estado en el centro de las
críticas de Los partidarios de la
invasión que le culpan del lento avance
y de los retrocesos en la ofensiva rusa
en Ucrania
y una de las batallas más largas de la
guerra podría entrar en sus últimas
horas las fuerzas rusas afirman tener
abacmut prácticamente rodeada una
situación confirmada este sábado por la
inteligencia británica las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas sin embargo han
declarado que continúan los combates en
la ciudad asediada y Que de momento no
obedecen a la petición del grupo Wagner
de abandonar la zona para evitar más
bajas humanas veamos el informe
esta carretera es una de las únicas vías
de entrada y salida de bahamut la zona
ha sido testigo de los combates más
feroces de la guerra hasta ahora las
fuerzas rusas dicen que tienen la ciudad
casi completamente rodeada y es solo
cuestión de tiempo hasta que la tomen el
viernes el jefe de Wagner y Pío zinc
pidió al presidente ucraniano bolodimir
selenski que ordenará La retirada de
bajo mud para salvar la vida de sus
soldados pero según dichas tropas no
tienen planes de Rendirse
las fuerzas rusas están intentando rogar
al ejército ucraniano que abandone para
que dejemos de defender la ciudad
esperan hacerse con la ciudad sin
grandes pérdidas pero han perdido a
tanta gente que la catástrofe para el
grupo Wagner y el ejército ruso es
inevitablemente el viernes la agencia de
noticias Estatal rusa riano bosti
publicó estas imágenes muestran un
puente en las afueras de bahamut
reducido a escombros en el vídeo pueden
verse tropas pertenecientes al grupo
Mercenario Wagner afirman que fueron las
fuerzas ucranianas las que destruyeron
el puente intentando detener El Avance
ruso los que aún viven en la ciudad y
sus alrededores están sometidos a un
bombardeo casi constante solo quedan
unos 5.000 de los 70.000 que vivían
antes de la guerra y para los que quedan
es una lucha diaria
hay problemas con la comida solo nos dan
alimentos humanitarios una vez al mes no
hay electricidad ni agua ni gas tomar
sería una victoria altamente simbólica
para Rusia
Moscú considera la ciudad como un
trampolín para tomar ciudades más
grandes como kramators y slowns más al
oeste
en otras noticias el presidente francés
Emmanuel macron se encuentra ya en
República democrática del Congo la
última parada de su gira por el
continente africano que también lo llevó
a gabón Angola y Congo en kinghasa
decenas de manifestantes recibieron al
mandatario francés por un lado con el
rechazo a la influencia francesa en la
región y por otro lado con exigencias
para que París apoye sanciones contra
Ruanda estado al que la República
democrática del Congo acusa de estar
vinculado con Los Rebeldes de la
guerrilla del m-23 de hecho macron
anunció ayudas económicas a la ciudad de
goma al este del país en la zona
afectada por el conflicto
por ello Francia será el primer estado
en responder a la iniciativa de la Unión
Europea anunciada esta misma mañana de
Establecer un servicio aéreo humanitario
a goma liberaremos una aportación
inmediata de 34 millones de euros en
ayuda humanitaria que se sumarán a la
cantidad de casi 50 millones anunciada
por la Unión Europea
y en la capital china en Beijing empezó
este sábado una de las citas clave del
partido comunista china se trata de la
conferencia política consultiva número
14 del comité Nacional del pueblo chino
un evento que funciona como el antesala
del Congreso popular nacional que se
celebrará el domingo la doble cita pone
en marcha el plan trazado durante el
vigésimo Congreso Nacional del partido
comunista el año pasado cuando se aprobó
el inédito tercer mandato de shing Pink
como secretario general de la formación
y que con toda probabilidad
supondrá ahora su continuidad como
presidente del país entre los asuntos
nacionales en la agenda el escenario
postpandemia después de abandonar la
política cero covid por otro lado la
situación económica el desarrollo
militar o el conflicto entre Rusia y
Ucrania
vamos ahora con información de nuestra
región porque en Colombia esta ha sido
una semana complicada para el presidente
Gustavo Petro al que le han abierto
distintos frentes con crisis ministerial
protestas campesinas y sospechas de
corrupción en contra de su familia para
analizar todos estos eventos tenemos en
nuestro plato a nuestro periodista Iris
Muñoz ellos Muñoz buenos días qué tal
Rosa cómo estás bien una semana
complicada como decíamos con muchísimos
frentes para Petro tú misma lo dices
podemos decir que estamos ante una de
las semanas más críticas desde que Petro
es presidente en la que ha habido de
todo desde tres destituciones
ministeriales e incluso una batalla
tuitera entre Petro y su contraparte de
Salvador nayib bukele como son muchos
frentes empecemos concentrándonos por
una de las noticias también y ha sido un
informe no del comité de derechos
humanos de Naciones Unidas que mezcla
esperanza y condena hacia Colombia no
2022 uno de los años más violentos pero
también dice este comité que tiene fe
esperanza no en el plan de paz total de
este gobierno de Petro Así es Rosa Este
informe anual del alto comisionado de
los Derechos Humanos estuvo presentado
por la representante Juliette de Rivero
en el que dijo que había aumento de la
violencia en 2022 acercándonos a cifras
similares a las de antes del acuerdo de
paz entre el estado y las FARC de 2016
centrándonos en estos datos podemos ver
como los líderes sociales hubo 116
asesinatos en 2022 un incremento a los
100 de 2021 también las masacres pasaron
de las 78 de 2021 a las 92 de 2022
también hubo 50 excombatientes de las
farcas asesinados y ya son 355 al menos
los asesinados desde el año 2016 en el
que hubo la firma del acuerdo de paz
también hubo 103 miembros de la fuerza
pública asesinados y otro aumento en el
número de desplazado de 72.000 pasa a
82.000 por lo que como decías Juliette
de Rivero se mostró preocupada pero
también esperanzada entre esas reformas
que el gobierno de Gustavo Petro quiere
acometer como entre ellas la paz Total
que busca la fin del conflicto a seis
décadas después de seis décadas y en la
que también Juliette de Rivero dijo que
esto estas reformas van a necesitar
tiempo en relación a esta Esperanza que
comentas no y Luis precisamente el
presidente Gustavo Petro en medio de
este aluvión de problemas se felicitó
ayer felicitó concretamente al
Ministerio de defensa y de interior no
por la liberación de los 79 policías y
seis civiles que como avanzábamos en los
titulares de este informativo fueron
liberados ayer viernes después de ser
retenidos el jueves en medio de una
protesta campesina profundicemos en esto
sí así es San Vicente del caguán es un
municipio ubicado en el Sureño
departamento del caquetá que es la
puerta de entrada al amazonas y que
destacamos que es bueno era uno de los
bastiones de las FARC allá Durante un
mes hubo protestas campesinas debido a
que una empresa petrolera emeral Energy
que es una filial de una petrolera china
no había cumplido con los compromisos de
42 kilómetros de pavimentación de una
vía maltrecha por todo el tipo de cargas
que salen de las instalaciones
petrolíferas Entonces el jueves escaló
la situación y los campesinos llegaron a
retener a 79 policías y seis civiles
como comentabas finalmente en la
intermediación que hubo con el los
ministerios y con los distintos
funcionarios fueron liberados estas
personas y Petro dijo este es un
gobierno para dialogar este es un
gobierno que les pertenece y se
comprometió a visitar la zona para
continuar con esas negociaciones Cabe
destacar que estas tipo de disputas son
habituales en Colombia y es que muchas
multinacionales extractivistas causan
ciertos daños medioambientales que
afectan a las comunidades que no ven
como hay beneficios para ellas por esta
actividad multinacional también Cabe
destacar Que bueno hay un enfrentamiento
también entre las disidencias con el
estado y no están avanzando las
negociaciones por lo que también se cree
que detrás de estas protestas
disidencias de las extintas FARC
estarían detrás Okay es muy interesante
y precisamente para salir un poco al
paso continuar con poder continuar con
sus políticas y dejar de lado un poco
las críticas quizás más personales en el
seno de su familia como avanzábamos no
Petro sorprendió con una comunicado en
el que pide a la justicia colombiana que
Investiga a su hermano y a su hijo y nos
ha traído una portada del espectador
bastante ilustrativa con esta última
polémica no veamos esta portada del
espectador donde se ve en primer plano a
Gustavo Petro detrás a su hijo Nicolás
Petro y titulan con un contundente a sus
espaldas Y es que el jueves Gustavo
Petro emitió un comunicado en el que
pedía la fiscalía que investigase a su
hijo Nicolás Petro pero también a su
hermano Juan Fernando Petro al parecer
Nicolás Petro habría prometido
beneficios presidenciales a
narcotraficantes Y paramilitares a
cambio de dinero que financiaría la
campaña de Gustavo Petro sin embargo
Esto fue revelado por la exmujer de
Nicolás petron en la revista semana
sería Nicolás Petro quien se quedó esos
fondos y no fueron destinados finalmente
para la campaña en el caso del hermano
Juan Fernando Petro la fiscalía le está
investigando por haber prometido
beneficios judiciales a paramilitares y
narcotraficantes para entrar dentro de
la paz total a cambio de pagos el alto
comisionado para la paz de Colombia ha
confirmado uno de estos casos por lo que
por lo que como decía también el diario
El País en su Artículo decían como que
Gustavo Petro a diferencia del filósofo
albercamis en lugar de escoger entre
Cuando decía que entre la justicia y su
madre escogía a su madre Gustavo Petro
entre su familia y la justicia ha
escogido la justicia en este caso Bueno
lo necesita también para ser digamos no
con a sus promesas y pues eso no con la
campaña y con la política que ha
prometido el presidente de Colombia que
asumió el cargo recordemos el pasado mes
de agosto bueno Joyce Muchísimas gracias
por este análisis no sé si tiene algo
más que Añadir Gracias Rosa y estaremos
atentos a ver cómo continúa ya
acercándose al primer aniversario de la
presidencia ya cerca de agosto como
continúan estos meses que vienen con
reformas sociales y políticas y
judiciales vamos a ver cómo continúa
este gobierno de Gustavo Petro y Francia
Márquez ciertamente Luis porque esto se
nos ha quedado por fuera Pero ha habido
también muchísimo movimiento dentro del
gabinete Ministerial de Gustavo Petro
Bueno lo iremos comentando a lo largo de
estos días Gracias
nosotros cambiamos de información pero
seguimos en nuestra región Porque la
fiscal general de Ecuador Diana Salazar
solicitó este viernes el arresto
domiciliario para el expresidente Lenin
Moreno por un caso de corrupción la
decisión se da en el marco del caso sino
hidro que en torno a presuntos sobornos
recibidos por la construcción de la
central hidroeléctrica coca-colo
Sinclair la fiscal consideró necesaria
la prisión preventiva para los 37
imputados en el caso pero la
Constitución de Ecuador impide esa
medida para los mayores de 65 años como
es el caso de Lenin Moreno este domingo
la justicia decidirá cuantos sospechosos
Irán finalmente a prisión preventiva
vamos ahora a Indonesia para mostrarles
las imágenes de la explosión de una
estación de combustible en la capital
yakarta en el incidente ocurrido este
viernes murieron 17 personas 49
resultaron heridas de gravedad Y a esta
hora se cuentan al menos 18
desaparecidos según informaron las
autoridades de Indonesia el origen del
fuego fue la Caída de un rayo por otro
lado la compañía energética Estatal
portamina informó a la agencia de
información reuters que el incendio fue
extinguido a lo largo de esta noche y
que las reservas de combustible
permanecen en un estado seguro
llegamos así al final de esta edición
informativa pero sigan con nosotros y
con toda la información en France 24
y24.com
[Música]